[Music]
is a leading technology provider in the
energy sector and it started on its
cloud journey with the ambition to be
the leader in the energy solutions
industry in 2016 schlumberger partnered
with google as the provider for high
performance cloud computing this has
resulted in the industry-leading delphi
cognitive exploration and production
environment it is an open secure
scalable and fully managed ecosystem
connecting people data and leading
software applications for the across the
entire oil and gas exploration landscape
the door assessments have allowed us to
benchmark against others in the energy
and digital industries
we have now clearly seen that focusing
on the dora recommendations of test
automation continuous delivery and
monitoring has moved a significant
number of our solutions and services
into the high performance door
categories
we recognized early we needed to invest
in not just the cloud and technology
ecosystem but in all its associated
practices governance and the skills to
enable our people to deliver
best-in-class services to our customers
our goal is to improve the software
delivery and operational performance of
our cloud hosted products because we
want to deliver the best-in-class
service to our clients
so what attracted us was its holistic
evidence-based approach where it focuses
us to improve on the most impactful
technical process and cultural
capabilities the impact is measured by
the four dora metrics covering
throughput and stability
also
helped us to understand the results and
determine the most effective way
in order to
the most effective steps to take next so
this has been one of the critical things
which is being i identifying what is the
most impactful improvement to make next
and the google team have been incredibly
responsive in in helping us with this
it's been a very very good collaborative
relationship
we would like to thank all the staff at
slumberjay for their commitment and
dedication to improving our customers
experience by the wholehearted adoption
of the dora initiative
and finally thanks to google for this
award
you